ran out there the screamy rebounding  boom looks like this for molding what a  stroke that was averaged 18 the game  whoo showed some handles area he loves  that  that's his move oh yeah get a piece in  the lane [ __ ] airhorn he pump fakes in  there this gives very good  so every little hesitation  [Applause]  moodini got to the basket  let the Gator back there was a key puck  now Francis they break it down won't  they catch in there a threat that was  deep and warm who's the guy covered big  with the Red Raiders tap on the head  they usually like to run a high-low they  got away from it look at this kid again  goodness  that was mash like right there they want  to take their guys sometimes you get in  the building you get in the zone you get  in the moment so nice help booty gets  inside henry autumn fades back look at  this fish  soft touch he's got a handle